novembre 2006 l'élection contestée de
jeu vient moïse à la présidence est la
goutte qui fait déborder le vase pour
bien des haïtiens dans les mois qui
suivent ou une chaîne ji sun perd son
poste de directeur médical sa femme ou
six médecins part seul pour montréal en
quête d'une vie meilleure pour la
famille allard volonté que j'arrête de
venir était plus grand et le stress que
j'avais là bas je pensais que je pouvais
surmonter tout ce que je pourrais
trouver au québec pendant deux ans rose
fait mille et un petits boulots très
loin de la médecine
quand son mari la rejoint en octobre
elle travaille dans un entrepôt leurs
deux enfants vivent en floride dans la
famille de rose le temps qui s'installe
un peu mieux à montréal puis la pandémie
survient je me suis dit arrête là c'est
une opportunité une grande opportunité
parce que déjà en fait chez moi et je
travaille plus dans le domaine be que
j'ai fait beaucoup de gens parce que je
travaille dans le choléra dans le
tremblement de terre en avril winch 1 se
joint à la brigade de prévention et de
contrôle des infections de la santé
publique de montréal vient tout juste de
créer des dizaines de médecins formés à
l'étranger sont embauchés
ils vont dans les établissements ériger
des ondes rouge et aider le personnel à
mieux se protéger dans un système de
santé européen
on peut changer des vies changent et des
conditions de vie aider les gens moi
c'était vraiment ça m'a vraiment le
chedi a fait la pandémie je vais pouvoir
aider au début rose nous pas quitter son
poste permanent un entrepôt pour un
emploi temporaire mais quand elle voit
le moral et l'humeur de son mari se
transforme et qu'elle le voit ce dévoué
sans compter les heures
elle décide de plonger ils ont vu la
post là la potentialité de prendre ces
gens et de leyme de de les faire briller
de mettre leur savoir je pense que ça
nous a permis d'être grill réseau de la
santé de comprendre la république ici ce
qui m'a beaucoup manqué et plus dans
delabrière
les faucons a fait avec les milieux par
exemple lorsqu'il les avait beaucoup de
cas le pic était vraiment au avec
beaucoup de formations qu'on a fait
beaucoup de milieux qu'on a visités et
puis on a regardé on a vu que la coupe
commence à baisser
ça donne un sentiment de de quelque
chose de bien accompli qu'on a qu'on a
et dès qu'on a vraiment aidé qu'on avait
ce qu'on a fait vraiment une différence
et inversement la pandémie a apporté au
couple une certaine paix faire le deuil
d'une carrière de médecin
ce moins mal si on peut travailler dans
le milieu de la santé et avoir des
revenus stables ou une chaîne vient
d'obtenir un poste permanent à la santé
publique de montréal
je peux continuer dans le même domaine
dans les domaines de la prévention de
prévention et contrôle des infections
je vais rester là
nous verrons ça va être beaucoup plus
facile ça va être plus facile pour vous
défier
oui parce que s'il a un poste permanent
c'est sûr que moi je peux aller aux
études lille peut continuer à travailler
oui en leur permettant de mieux gagner
leur vie
la pandémie a aussi provoqué
d'émouvantes retrouvailles
le plus jeune est arrivé à montréal en
août dernier est heureuse de les voir se
trouve mon fils parce que ça faisait
quand même un bout de temps que je les
ai pas vus ce com ya une grande
différence tant il est revenu quand il
est venu et là maintenant il est plus
content il est très pâle
il est très épanoui je pense que c'était
la meilleure chose à faire
ils sont vraiment très très épanouie
même s'il commence à peine à parler
français mais se réduit à sybille belles
choses mais elle se débrouille assez
bien à l'école aussi avec les
professionnels pourraient se développer
il ne s'attendait pas à ce qu'il allait
s'adapter aussi vite et aussi ils sont
contents
[Applaudissements]